when it comes to constants like that
five up the top there
um we do have the ability to actually
move them around
quite flexibly which is going to be
really handy for us so
um because that five is there and it's
kind of not really
making things any easier to integrate
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
factorize it out of the integral
all together okay so i'll pull that 5
out the front
and then i want to think about what do i
have left on the inside of the integral
so what am i going to get left one over
x perfect which is just log
exactly so you're like oh i know what
the integral and then you bring phi
i know what the primitive of this is
it's that um log
of the absolute value of x like we're
talking about but then you're like oh
well the five was just hanging out the
front there so i best
bring that back right um and then this
is indefinite so i add my constant on
does that make sense so i didn't know
how to do it i just didn't yeah yeah you
do back yourself
should we should we have a look at a
harder one sure yeah let's let's pick
out
so um you you seem to
sound reasonably confident can we ever
go at say um
let's have a go
i'm gonna pull out this one here f do
you see that one there yep this is uh
question two f
okay so um we've got a 15 on the top
and i've got a five x plus one dx so
what what's your instinct for the first
thing to do in this question
um
well recognize a pattern so
i don't like that plus one because if i
did not have that plus one i'd be able
to simplify
into basically what we were doing before
yes the fireworks
right right right and you're like oh
this can just simplify very quickly
right
now here's a sneaky thing right um
you're right to look at this plus one
and think uh
be gross right i don't want that and
that's like in some ways i did something
very similar on this earlier example
when i was like oh look at this let's
just break that apart right
now the issue you're going to run into
though is that
with denominators not so easy right so
um fractions are weird in that the
numerators and denominators
behave very differently right in a real
way what the numerator is telling you
is um whatever whatever kind of number
we're dealing with how many
do you have right and then what the
denominator is telling you is
yeah that's right it's like what are the
containers what's the size you know what
what kind
like you're telling me how many but what
what kind of thing do we even
have right and we encountered this like
way back in year seven when we were like
oh a half plus a third man what do i do
with that you're like
like the first things in halves and the
other things in thirds and they talk a
completely different language
so that's why we had to get common
denominators and all that but you're
like oh like that was work right
and the reason it's worked is because uh
well some people once once you master it
you're like oh i'm good at this right
you're like
six and then off you go okay so the
upshot of this
here um is that this denominator
is not easy to just break apart i should
point out and we can have a look at
examples later if you like
denominators are not impossible to deal
with um but
as it turns out in this case i actually
can leave
the denominator in in the form that it's
in
i want you to think back to let's go
back to the reference sheet for a second
here it is okay
we were looking at this formula here in
the middle before
right so if we can have our integral
look like f dash
on f then we're good to go yeah
let's look at this question um if the
denominator
is amazing if the denominator there is
my f of x
so what i'm suggesting is f of x equals
five that's a very messy fight five
minutes
plus one right if that's my f of x what
would
f dash be five it'll be five right now
in this case what you'll notice is
because i'm differentiating the plus one
actually presents me with no problems
right because i differentiate yeah
exactly exactly
it's like the constant which just it
could be anything it just disappears
when i differentiate
yes exactly right so i'm like i want
i want this numerator to be five but
it's not five it's
three times five right which means that
it's a it's just a multiple
of what i really want there to be so
that's actually enormously helpful to me
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to write this and we'll do
every step right as you suggested i'm
going to say well that's 3 times 5
on the denominator 5x plus 1
still on the did i say denominator i
should just a numerator
okay so i've got 3 times 5 on the
numerator but because i don't want 3
times 5 i just want the 5.
so what i'll do is just like i did on
this question up here
i'm like i'm just gonna i'm just going
to take it out another three yeah i'm
just going to factorize out that 3.
it comes out the front of the integral
what that leaves me with is 5 on 5x plus
1.
and this is my magical f dash on f you
can even see it
over here here's 5 here's five x plus
one so there's just
three other next yeah three earlier now
hold on a second
it's 3ln and you can even see over here
it's actually log of
whatever that function is that f of x
that denominator is
right you see that so it's log of
whatever function which in this case
is five x plus one do you see that whole
thing
yeah it's the whole thing so this whole
piece here is the f
x right so that's why the whole thing
ends up underneath we did these
questions
yeah it's been a while it's been a while
but so that's that's why it's worth um
refreshing our memories
so yeah that's it's part of the job
right so
i mean it's tricky because we are
expecting you like i always thought
about this um
when i was uh at school because i um
i thought like i'm trying to learn all
these very separate subjects to each
other like
history drama i did like hsc agriculture
and it's like these have nothing to do
with each other you try to like
mash them into your brain can you
imagine if you had like some
professional athlete right and you said
to them hey so
um what what sport are you training in
and they're like ah
well um i'm doing pole vaulting
i'm a pole vaulter but i'm also working
on my archery
and also my gymnastics and also
chess just cause and you'd be like are
you serious like you're specializing
shouldn't you be it's like well actually
that's exactly what we're asking you
guys to do
by learning these very different
subjects so you shouldn't feel bad that
your brain is slightly muddled about it
but the more you consolidate and
practice
you know regularly um it's sort of all
cements itself